nous en arrivons maintenant au troisième
projet le troisième projet c'est le plus
important
certains dirais même que c'est sans
doute le plus fou il est en train d'être
présenté officiellement en ce moment en
ce moment même au président de la région
valéry giscard d'estaing c'est un projet
qui est né entre la commune d'orcines et
le volcanologue maurice krafft la
chambre de commerce de clermont issoire
a initié ce projet avec un spécialiste
en la matière font de boer franck bauer
et maurice krafft sont venus nous
présenter leur projet cet après midi il
y à peine une heure bien disons que
c'est un rêve d'enfant il ya longtemps
que j'ai considère le puits dom com un
site unique en europe et que j'estime
qu'il faudrait il faire un à la fois un
espèce de musée qui sera le plus grand
musée volcanologique de la planète est
aussi un parc scientifique
donc ce serait une structure vivante sur
les volcans est une structure qui ferait
rêver parce que le rêve de tout homme
c'est d'aller au centre de la terre et
là ce sera pratiquement impossible
puisque juste pour vous donner quelques
idées en descendant dans un ascenseur et
sur les parois de l'ascenseur on verra
la croûte terrestre puis on verra le
manteau terrestre puis le noyau externe
ouailles ont été reconstruits au sens de
la terre et ensuite on circulera sous
terre dans différents types de salles
une représentante du volcan qui serait
mieux rond mais vraiment bien fait je
veux dire pratiquement en relief où on
verra véritablement le volcan qui se
réveille en pressant sur un bouton
également les sons et cela fait d'une
façon scientifique on se trouvera
également dans une salle où on sera
comme dans un planétarium où l'on verra
la croûte terrestre de l'intérieur donc
on verra les plaques envers les volcans
et on sera au centre de la terre et on
va vers l'extérieur vers les courants de
convection sous forme de rayons lasers
et tout ça se terminera par une remontée
du puy d'hommes depuis la base jusqu'au
sommet par l'ascenseur et donc le
spectateur le visiteur sera rejeté par
le volcan au sommet du piton et je t'en
vas là il verra ses tuyaux absolument
fabuleuse et l'a pratiquement la visite
s'achèvera en beurre ou vous êtes un des
spécialistes de l'aménagement de ce
genre
deux parcs mais c'est pas du tout un
parc d'attraction avec des schtroumpfs
ou des milk et c'est quelque chose de
sérieux de scientifiques c'est un peu
votre fils votre philosophie dans ce
genre d'affaires c'est tout à fait ma
philosophie j'essaye depuis longtemps
d'introduire une attitude nouvelle dans
la communication je pense que les gens
apprennent beaucoup plus ils abusent
c'est un phénomène que les américains
ont bien compris par exemple si vous
allez à epcot vous apprenez beaucoup de
choses dont vous pouvez même pas vous
promenant vous êtes véhiculé à travers
des espaces qui vous apprennent des
choses et vous apprenez en vous amusant
d'une manière très spectaculaire et je
crois que si on veut ramener vous savez
vous de la télévision vous avez gâté le
public et le public a besoin maintenant
d'une forme de communication beaucoup
plus vivante qu'avant et il faut le lui
donner par des musées tout à fait
différent ce que j'appelle les nouveaux
musées qui sont des buses et des
champions typhi qu avec tous les moyens
d'expression les plus modernes et les
plus dramatiques dramatiser par le
cinéma par la vidéo par toutes sortes de
moyens et par des transports des moyens
de transport comme ce que maurice krafft
évoqué mais reste le prix de ce projet
l'heure actuelle on l'évalué entre 600 à
800 millions de francs c'est à dire
entre 60 milliards et 80 milliards de
centimes oui ce que vous pensez de ce
financier c'est un chiffre qui moi me
paraît raisonnable compte tenu de ce que
la communication moderne coûte cher
évidemment ce qui coûte le moins cher
s'est fait rappeler aux comme ça mais
quand vous voulez faire d'une
communication très spectaculaire ça
coûte beaucoup plus cher
l'édifice cook s'est également creusé ce
grand tube qui va descendre au fond
c'est également cher et je crois que de
toute façon la france a besoin de
s'équiper et cette région a besoin d'un
très bel équipement spectaculaire je
crois pour attirer les gens en plus ça
vous avez deux autoroutes qui vont se
croiser ici à clermont ferrand
il faut que le public se sentent attirés
par quelque chose en passant ici ce
serait dommage de laisser défiler
complètement que personne ne s'arrête
une question tout de même heureuse grave
aussi creusé au centre de ce volcan
pas vraiment écouté en fait on pourrait
imaginer c'est un rêve secret et que je
suis machiavélique que voudrait voir une
éruption volcanique au sommet du puy de
dôme et enfin franchement pas du tout
par exemple au vésuve
il a été fait des forages dans le
cratère du vésuve qui allait jusqu'à
2000 mètres de profondeur rien de ces
produits je reviens du piton de la
fournaise à la réunion est bien dans le
cratère du piton de la fournaise en a
fait récemment les forages de 3000
mètres de profondeur et en font des
trous au fond du forage
il n'y avait que deux cents 300 degrés
est ici franchement soupe puis doc c'est
pratiquement froid si ce projet se
réalise ce sera votre rêve qui se
réalisait pas tout à fait ce sera
sûrement le plus grand musée où la plus
grande de plus grand parc d'attractions
volcanologique du monde ce sera
franchement quelque chose de très
original et il n'y a qu'en auvergne
qu'on peut faire un musée pareil